[Music]
from guillermo del toro the latino Peter
Jackson comes a completely original
sci-fi universe that doesn't rely on any
pre-existing franchise as long as you
don't count transformers Ultraman Power
Rangers Godzilla Rock'em Sock'em robots
and stupid Hugh Jackman robot boxing
movie or every anime ever made Pacific
Rim when giant aliens emerge from this
iTunes visualizer at the bottom of the
ocean the entire world's resources will
be spent on building giant robots to
punch them in the face but these
machines are only as good as their two
pilots who for no reason at all
must be connected by an overly
complicated neural bridge to ensure
drift compatibility a system so advanced
only family members can do it we would
drift compatible or just to random
strangers we are drift compatible for
just one guy by himself this makes no
sense but it sure looks cool meet
Raleigh Beckett a hotshot pilots
struggling to maintain his American
accent all those years I spent living in
the past
never really thought about the future
and his copilot Mako Mori a girl so bad
at speaking English other fighting
techniques and stress sometimes she just
gives up mid-sentence you promise to me
well this today you're going to cut it
watches these two awkwardly flirt in the
classic will they won't they
relationship then for the first time in
movie history won't
Suda with these badass fighting robots
crimson typhoon Cherno alpha destructor
Eureka and this one named after a
stripper [ __ ] danger who comes fully
equipped with ineffective elbow rockets
painfully slow plasma cabbages
and an incredibly powerful sword they
forgot they had until about two thirds
of the way through the movie probably
should have busted that out at the
beginning of the movie
let's think right along with a marshal
an ex-pilot force to take cancer walking
future Altoids but no amount of future
cancer can stop him from giving the most
awesome speech since Independence Day
hell yeah so free live the summer's
guiltiest pleasure that's either the
most awesome dumb movie ever made or the
dumbest awesome movie ever made
awesome so dumb story things your inner
nine-year-old will love giant robots
giant monsters giant robots punching
giant monsters using shipping crates as
brass knuckles using a freighter like a
baseball bat bo staff fighting colors
the dog is aha that's got three yards
that one part where he's alike in the
cut you saw awesome dumb robot movie
time Pacific Rim let's be honest
that movie was super dumb but I still
cannot wait for the sequel thanks for
watching be sure to subscribe
only you can prevent forest fires 60% of
the time it works every time
I'm not locked in here with you you're
locked in here with me I am a banana